american politicians have come up with
some pretty great acronyms over the
years there is of course the uniting and
strengthening america by providing
appropriate tools required to intercept
and obstruct terrorism act of 2001 also
known as the patriot act the usa patriot
act there is the uniting and
strengthening america by fulfilling
rights and ensuring effective discipline
over monitoring act of 2015
or the
usa freedom act boy that's a good
acronym
but i think that florida governor ron
desantis may have just come up with the
best one yet
a new piece of legislation for the
upcoming legislative session called stop
wrongs against our kids and employees
act the stop woke act and it's something
that
the stop woke act an excellent acronym
and an even more excellent piece of
legislation i totally love the stop woke
act i don't only love it because of how
great the acronym is that the acronym is
magnificent i love it because of what
the law does governor desantis tell us
what it does
and this will do a number of things that
are very important one it will put into
statute
the department of education's
prohibition on crt in k-12 schools no
taxpayer dollars
should be used to teach our kids to hate
our country or to hate each other
and and that's important and that's all
well and good but i think what we've
seen recently is you can legislate
things like parents bill of rights you
can have certain things and sometimes
the school districts don't always follow
it and so we are going to be including
in this legislation
giving parents a private right of action
to be able to enforce the prohibition on
crt and they get to recover attorneys
fees
when they prevail which is very
important
[Applause]
this is
really good
stuff
this is a great use by conservatives of
the government to save our culture he
says it right there he says the
legislation has to have teeth it's one
thing to pass it but how are you going
to enforce it well one way you're going
to enforce it is a
allowing a private right of action for
these parents to go after the schools
this is just sort of thing that you saw
in the texas pro-life law
where you are empowering citizens to sue
the abortionists so there's a mechanism
in there to actually hold these people
accountable we know that the teachers
because of the teacher unions are
unaccountable
they're plenty of good teachers out
there and there are a lot of really bad
teachers out there
and you can't really discriminate
between the two because the teacher
unions are so strong they're going to do
whatever they want we know that
administrations are not really held to
account all that often in in the school
districts and so here's one way we can
do it the parents can actually take
legal action here for the stop
woke act
i suspect
the squishy people
i suspect maybe some of the libertarians
they're not going to like this very much
because
this is imposing limits on academic
freedom and the freedom of teachers and
it's limiting things in the classroom
yeah right that's what that's what you
have to do that's what you have to do
that's the only way
that you can have a coherent culture
academic i've said it before i wrote a
book about this called speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now great book to put in a
christmas stocking
the libs used the nonsensical concept of
academic freedom the hoax in william f
buckley jr's words of academic freedom
to cram in all of their insane ideas
into the curriculum and when they put in
all of their crazy ideas that
necessarily crowded out all of the other
ideas the good conservative normal true
ideas and contradicted them in many
cases so what we need to do if we want
to be able to take that back if we want
to be able to take back education which
means if we want to be able to take back
the next generations of americans we
have got to push out all the crazy
left-wing ideas
and
the stop woke act is a great way to do
it hey i'm glad you liked that clip but
hold up
ring that bell please
that would be great i'd appreciate it
get the notifications you won't miss an
episode and if
some of our friends uh do have you miss
an episode in the big tech world head on
over to apple podcast spot if i stitch
your google play wherever you get your
audio podcast subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you